Thank you.
So hello everyone, my name is Raul.
I'm excited to talk to you today.
It's my first JSConf 2014 and it is really
blowing my mind.
So, before getting to topic, let me introduce
myself, I come from Spain, where I work as
a freelance developer, and I'm also studying
masters degree in computer technologies focus
on data compression, crip crip and steganography.
‑‑ crypt technology autography.
Let's start with data compression, first of
all, I'm not an expert on data compression,
I am learning about it, and I will like to
share with you what I know really.
So, for me, data compression is an amazing
topic.
When I say amazing, it is really amazing,
I promise.
It can be seen like magic, okay, data compression
algorithm take some data and reduce it's size
without losing investigation.
In some cases like logic compression it may
be interesting to lose some information that
means once the compressed the result will
not be identical.
For example in images, sounds, movies, they
are more suitable to of use logic compression.
On the other hand text is usually compressed
using a lossless method like him HTML file‑‑
it's not magic, we have tools to determine
how far we can go in come pressing data without
loosing information or quantify much information
is in a given message.
And this is with information theory introduce
by Claud etiane nonin 1948 in mathematical
theory of communication‑‑ his famous
paper.
So, how can we determine how much information
is contained in a message? Okay.
That answer is Entropy.
The Entropy, you can forget the formula for
now, the Entropy is the
A A amount of information contained in each
message.
In binary for example, we can concern Entropy
the number of bits to represent the message
without losing information.
The concept of Entropy is quite abstract,
and it's not always easy to understand.
But, how a message can contain more information
than other? Okay, it doesn't make any sense.
Imagine for example these two places, Berlin
and the Desert of Arizona.
We would say it is raining in Berlin it contains
less information than if we say it is raining
in the Desert of Arizona.
That is because it is less common.
In Berlin they have 225 days‑‑ rainy
days per year, 62percent.
While in the Desert of Arizona only 17 days,
which is six percent.
So information theory Entropy is closely related
to probabilities, as you can see in the formula.
And while this is mostly theoretical our brains
are already designed to come press data, we
do it all the time.
For example, we use multiconstruct to express
complex information like feelings with just
a couple of characters we can communicate
that we're happy, we're sad, we are mocking
you.
We also have acronyms for common sentences,
we no longer say laugh out loud we just say
LOL or ASAP for as soon as possible.
Savoring time while speaking and saving space
when storing it.
Even in real life we can share so much information
by facial eggs presentations, okay, like the
face is telling us if he's safe, happy and
having a good time.
Of these two examples we could consider a‑‑
facial eggs presentation as a form of logic
compression.
Information is being missed here.
In the other hand acronyms, if they are unique
and well defined, okay, we can decode it uniquely
would be a form of lossless compression.
But, even before the information theory was
developed, data compression was already a
key factor for assigning codes to communicate.
Take the Morse code for example, to save time
and Bandwidth Mors code assigned shorter code
to more frequent character ferreters.
For example in the English language, the Morse
code character‑‑ the most used character
is the letter E, so in Morse it is the shortest
code, it is just a dot.
So, what about data compression in web sites?
Okay, this is the normal flow, okay, the browser
sends AEC request to a server to get the file
for example index.HTML letting the server
know that accept the zip content.
The sever then reads the file, come presses
on the fly, usually, and sends it to the browser,
okay, unless we con fight your the server
to‑‑ content, it does it on the fly.
Finally, the browser deCOM presses the file
also on the fly, again and gives the reader
content.
We will see later having to compress and the
compress on the fly requires to have a compressional
algorithm that ise is fast to come press and
fast to decompress in both direction.
Let's see how GZIP works internally.
GZIP is a file formate, it ise it is a file
format based and a compression algorithm,
the actual compression takes place in the
detailed‑‑‑‑ it was designed by
this man, Phil Katz for the PK zip archiving
tool and is used for HTTP, PNG and PDF files.
Okay.
Unfortunately the history of Phil Katz, he
was a genius, but he died when he was only
37 due to complications related to chronic
alcoholism.
So, deplait is a combination of two algorithms,
LZ 77 and Hufpmann coding.
Let's see how they work.
LZ 77 is a losse lossless data compression,
we get the original data once come pressed.
Which is a compression by replacing repeated
occurrence of data with references, okay.
So, in this example, of we see how the algorithm
tries to find repeated occurrences and for
example files that space file, space file
spice, is spice appears twice.
So, replaces the second occurrence with a
reference.
The first number is the distance, okay, the
jump, the number of positions you need to
go back to go to the other stream.
And the second number is the length, the length
of the match.
So the decoder can uniquely decode that information.
To find matches, the algorithm keeps track
of recently read data, of 232 kilobyte, this
is called the sliding window.
We refer sometimes LZ 77 as a sliding Al gosh
rhythm.
Once come pressed we have three times of data
in the compressed stream.
We have literals, which would be the characters
that have not been replaced by references,
we have lengths, the length of the match,
and distances, the jump.
Okay, and in the second step, the algorithm
tries to use‑‑ bits for the zero, one
approach would be to use the necessary bits
to represent the symbols.
For example here we have the string hello
word, we will use ASCII, it uses 8 bits per
character, we would need 88 bits to represent
that information, that message.
As we are only using the characters that appear
in the table, they can be represented only
with 3 bits, so we can make a transformation
and use only 3 bits to represent the message.
So, we will of only 33 bits to represent that
information.
But we can do it better.
Instead of fix length codes we can use variable
length codes.
So, if we‑‑ if we calculate the frequency,
the number of appearances of the characters,
we can try to think shorter goals to more
frequent symbols like the Morse code does.
So, in this example L is used three times.
The letter O is just twice, and the others
only once.
So, we could do this and only use 19 bits
instead of 33 to represent the message.
Okay, but there is a problem.
The come pressed stream is ambiguous.
These four bits could be, for example, HE,
which is correct, A H which is 00 and E which
is 01, but it could also be LHO, L 0, H 00
and of O 1.
Also the O and many others, so we will need
to‑‑ our next thing is to separate that
code using compression ratio.
And here is when huffman coding comes, it
generates variable length codes, shorter codes
to more frequent characters, but they have
the prefixed property, the prefixed property
says that any of the codes is a prefix of
another.
So, the output can be decodeble it is not
ambiguous.
So using huffman coding it can be represented
with 32 bits, one bit less than you see in
the previous code.
And for larger messages gains could be even
better.
So, Huffman code is used using the compressed
output we got from LC 77.
One for literals and length and the second
for distances.
So if we go out now to the GZIP file, not
the algorithm, the format file, it come presses
an input data in blocks, okay, each block
is compressed separately.
And there are three modes of compression.
In mode one there is no compression at all.
It is just useful for data that is already
come pressed or data that is totally random
that cannot be come pressed.
Mode two uses some already generated Huffman
codes using some statistical analysis which
fits good enough for most data, and mode three
generate those code tables taking into account
the data of the block.
The mode one is the fastest.
And mode three is the slowest, but usually
gets better compression ratios.
Of of security, you're familiar with‑‑
you probably have use in the the past to use
to split big files into several chunks the
size of floppy disks, the non‑compression
mode to make these chunks.
Okay, so, we just saw how this works you may
have noticed this there are different ways
to generate the GZIP compliant file, just
splitting the file into several blocks with
no compression, the no compression mode we
get GZIP compliant file, it is really fast
but there is no compression at all.
And there are a lot of‑‑ able to create
the zip files, each of them use their own
optimizations, so the result will be different.
Also, there are compression modes, for example
the high compression mode spends more time
in LC 77 trying to find a longer match, okay.
In general 7 zip gets better compression ratio
than GNU GZIP, for example Zopfli follows
a different approach‑‑ this is from
Google, what it does is spend much more time,
when I say much more time, it is much more
time, around a hundred times slower to get
better compression ratios.
Okay, around five percent.
This is really useful if we want to come press,
for example our JavaScript files or CSS files
before deploying, okay, in the deployment
process.
And then serve those the zip files instead
of come pressing on the fly.
As a general rule, more time, using more time,
you get better compression ratios, so you
need the find a trade off between doing it
off line and up load the come pressed files
or doing it on the fly.
Why GZIP, it is the best compression method?
The answer is no.
There are many compression algorithms with
better compression ratios than GZIP, so why
are we still using GZIP? Most of the time
in computer science, there are trade offs.
GZIP provides good enough compression ratio
between 2.5 and 3 for text and it is fast,
it is fast to come press data and it is fast
to deCOM press it.
As we usually can figure out come press responses
on the fly, this is something to take into
account.
In addition, even in the worse case, for example
if the data is already compressed, expands
the data just a little bit by only five bites
by 32‑kilo bytes.
We try to compress everything it is important
to be sure that damages will be relatively
low.
Also, the memory needed by‑‑ the decoder
is independent of the size of the data.
And finally there are free implementation
that avoids‑‑ it is also difficult to
newer compression methods to be widely used.
For example the Chromium team tried a few
years ago for G.Zip 2 it provides better compression
ratio and the results are fast.
The problem was that even though the ACTP
were correct, and the contents were compressed
be B zip 2 the approximateee some of the intermediary
proxies didn't understand it.
‑‑ so it was corrupting if data.
So, basically, in the short term, at least,
we are stuck in the GZIP.
What can we do to try to get better compression
ratios? So, we can preprocess the data to
try to optimize matches.
Okay, take a look at this image.
This image was generated by a tool of‑‑
here mall showing what parts are compressed
file have been compressed better, those are
in blue, and what parts have been expanded.
So, we can see the strings of characters in
upper case or sometimes the first character
of capitalized words expand.
Of this is spectral behavior as they are less
common and more difficult to find a match
to replace with a reference.
But preprocess this data to try to optimize
the compression and the answer is, yes, sometimes.
The goal would be to have a functionality
able to transform the data in a way that once
is the zip is smaller than the original data
is zipped without losing information.
And, this depends highly on the type of data
we are using.
For example there is a technique called transposing
JSON, as you know JSON object is made of keycal
you pairs where the key portion is repeated
for each instance.
The basic idea is to group together all the
values for each property, so, in the example,
the name property will contain all the names
and the country property will contain all
the countries.
Obviously, we will need to change our client‑side
JavaScript to be able to read this.
But, doing this, we have two main benefits,
the first one is that we reduce redene dun
Dennis, we are making the files smaller at
the expense of spending more time or CPU cycles
in the client to interpret that information.
But, we are also grouped in similar data together.
If you remember when we talked about LC 77
it has a sliding window of 33‑kilo bytes.
We make sure that similar data, in this case
names or countries will be closed, so it is
more likely to find matches between similar
data.
It is important to note that not always we
will better compression ratio with this technique,
so we must be careful.
For XML and HTML files I have been working
on an automatic process in order to order
the attributes in a way to maximize LC 77
matches.
Here executing executing LC 77, only LC 77,
not the detail completely, over the first
sample we get an improvement of the file size
of 17percent.
As attributes get more ordered, we see the
percentage is bigger, so, in general it will
follow up to the other attributes, we'll get
slightly better results.
The process is not as simple as also takes
into account the value of the attribute, but,
just having a kind of standard to organize
your attributes you will get better results.
You can see there's a link at the bottom with
a small paper on it.
So, finally, if you have interest on data
compression and GZIP, okay, some recommended
material, of compression is a series of videos
of data compression, okay.
They are done by Colt McAnlis, which makes
it easy to understand and funny.
So, want to thank him for reviewing this presentation.
This is my favorite book on the topic.
It is data compression, the complete reference.
I am not sure if it's the best idea for a
beginner to start with this, but if you're
curious to know how a given algorithm‑‑
the answer is here, the book is quite expensive
so ...
so if you're not going to read it, don't buy
it.
And if you like, reading papers I recommend
to read this one from Jay cob Zif and abbra
ham Lempel where they talk about LC 77.
And finally the paper written by David Hutchman
on the construction of minimum redundancy
codes, it's a very short paper around 12 pages.
But the impact on data compression and other
fields has been huge.
And that's all, thank you, hope you enjoyed
(Applause).